Allez, on en refait une,
faut nous départager.
T’es mauvais perdant toi ?
Mais nan, mais la dernière partie, le vent était contre nous.
Là, on en refait une,
et le perdant, il fait à manger.
“De tout temps les hommes se sont crus au centre de l’univers”,
n’est certainement pas la phrase par laquelle je commencerais,
déjà parce que “de tout temps les hommes” c’est de mauvais goût,
et ensuite parce que c’est plutôt faux.
En fait, il y a eu assez tôt des philosophes pour soutenir que nous n’occupons pas une place particulièrement centrale ni même significative dans l’univers, non.
Dès le Ve siècle av. J.-C, les premiers atomistes Leucippe et Démocrite
soutenaient que la Terre n’est qu’un agrégat de matière tombant dans le vide
parmi bien d’autres s’entrechoquant dans un grand jeu de pétanque cosmique.
Et cette idée sera reprise un peu plus tard par Épicure qui écrivait sans sourciller :
“Il y a un nombre infini de mondes semblables au nôtre et un nombre infini de mondes différents.”
Et, toujours pour Épicure, il y a entre ces mondes des dieux bienheureux
qui n’ont rien mais alors vraiment rien à faire
de nos petites existences médiocres.
Donc yolo. (Bon ok là, je paraphrase un peu, mais c’est l’esprit.)
Ce type de cosmologie qui fait de notre Terre une place insignifiante et dérisoire dans un univers aveugle et chaotique,
cela semble coller assez bien à l’idée que nous nous en faisons aujourd’hui,
mais il est vrai que cette conception restait très très marginale dans l’Antiquité.
La cosmologie dominante dans la pensée scientifique grecque puis européenne avant l’époque moderne,
c’est une cosmologie géocentriste, c’est-à-dire que la Terre y est conçue comme immobile au centre de l’univers.
Et du coup unique, forcément.
Comme toutes les grandes erreurs scientifiques,
on attribue celle-ci avant tout à Aristote qui en effet développa
un système géocentriste dont l’influence aura été très importante,
même si en fait la référence majeure en astronomie à partir du IIe siècle n’est pas le système d’Aristote directement mais le système de Ptolémée,
qui s’oppose à ce dernier sur pas mal de points
mais qui adhère bien à cette conception géocentriste.
Alors était-ce par stupidité, par mégalomanie ou par amour d’Aristote
que les savants ont si longtemps soutenus qu’ils étaient au centre de l’univers ?
En fait, non, on va voir pourquoi nous avons eu, pendant longtemps, de très bonnes raisons de le croire.
Et ça permettra de réfléchir de façon plus large à la façon dont notre conception de la Terre et du reste de l’univers a évolué au fil de l’histoire de la pensée scientifique.
Déjà, halte au préjugé sur les géocentristes.
C’est pas parce qu’on pense que la Terre est immobile au centre de l’univers qu’on pense aussi qu’elle est plate. C’est même plutôt l’inverse.
Le géocentrisme et la Terre sphérique ça se marie parfaitement.
L’idée sous-jacente étant en gros que les corps lourds sont mus vers un même point central de l’univers, formant ainsi par accumulation
une sphère centrée sur ce point.
Et voilà notre Terre ronde, immobile, au centre de l’univers,
tout ça est bien cohérent.
Par contre, du côté de la team atomiste de l’Antiquité pour qui il y a une infinité de mondes qui tombent dans le vide,
donc vraiment pas géocentriste pour un sou,
eh bien eux ils soutenaient que la Terre est plate, en forme de cylindre aplati apparemment.
(Donc plutôt que de pétanque j’aurais dû parler de curling cosmique tout à l’heure.)
Alors vous me direz “oui mais bon, tout le monde le pensait à l’époque, ça vaaaa…”,
sauf qu’en fait non, l’idée d’une Terre ronde est assez vite sur la table chez les Grecs.
Elle s’impose à partir du IVe siècle av. J.-C environ,
soit entre Démocrite et Epicure en gros.
Et quand Lucrèce, poète latin épicurien du Ier siècle av. J.-C.,
se moque des défenseurs d’une Terre ronde avec des habitants aux antipodes qui seraient attirés vers le centre de la Terre au lieu de tomber vers le bas évidemment,
c’est en décalage complet avec la pensée scientifique de son temps.
L’atomiste épicurien, c’est le platiste de l’époque, littéralement.
L’un des principaux auteurs à avoir fait pencher la balance du côté de la Terre ronde, c’est Aristote dans son Traité du ciel
qui donne une série d’arguments en faveur de la sphéricité de la Terre,
notamment des arguments fondés sur des observations astronomiques.
Parce que, oui, la forme de la Terre peut se voir indirectement dans le ciel,
notamment quand on observe l’ombre de la Terre lors d’une éclipse de Lune.
Le contour de cette ombre est parfaitement circulaire, quelle que soit la position de la Lune au moment de l’éclipse.
Or si la Terre avait la forme d’un palet de curling,
l’ombre n’aurait pas toujours ce contour circulaire. (On verrait parfois la tranche de la Terre, en quelque sorte.)
Le seul solide dont le contour de l’ombre est parfaitement circulaire quel que soit l’angle par laquelle cette ombre est projetée,
c’est la sphère,
et donc c’est cette forme-là seulement qui est cohérente avec ces observations d’éclipse.
C’est pas le seul argument chez Aristote, mais celui-ci est particulièrement élégant et solide.
Ainsi cette conception d’une Terre sphérique, immobile, au centre de l’univers (ou plus exactement dont le centre serait le centre de l’univers)
va devenir, à partir du IVe siècle av. J.-C. environ la position la plus largement acceptée en astronomie.
Allez, vas-y Thibaut, cette fois-ci, tu fais pas le con. Tout droit.
Mais c’est pas possible ! Mais t’es nul !
Je vais mettre de côté les questions qui touchent à l’immobilité de la Terre
(parce qu’en fait c’est plus compliqué qu’il n’y paraît).
Je vais ici surtout me pencher sur ce qui touche à la place de la Terre dans l’univers.
Pourquoi nous sommes-nous crus si longtemps au centre ?
Ça n’avait rien de stupide, naïf, ou narcissique, il y avait, entre autre, un argument astronomique de poids en faveur de cette idée,
un argument qui va revenir encore et encore pendant 2000 ans au bas mot,
l’argument de la parallaxe.
Mais qu’est-ce que la parallaxe me direz-vous ?
Eh bien pour l’expliquer,
je dois d’abord développer ce que ça voudrait dire d’être “au centre de l’univers”.
L’univers, c’est en somme tout ce qu’il y a, et notamment tout ce qu’il y a au-dessus de nos têtes dans le vaste ciel.
Et quand on y plonge le regard par une claire nuit d’été, ce qu’il y a de plus frappant et bêtement poétique,
ce sont tous ces petits trucs brillants qui parsèment de toute part le ciel nocturne.
La “voûte étoilée” comme on dit.
Tous ces astres se déplacent lentement au cours de la nuit mais ils occupent toujours la même position relative les uns par rapport aux autres.
Ils se déplacent d’un seul bloc.
En astronomie ancienne on parle pour cette raison d’“astres fixes” et de la “sphère des fixes”,
parce qu’à partir d’Aristote on a supposé que ces astres étaient tous accrochés à une même sphère en rotation autour de la Terre.
(Ceci dit l’argument astronomique dont je vais parler ensuite fonctionne tout aussi bien si on suppose que ces astres sont à des distances différentes de la Terre, donc peu importe.)
Vous me direz “et les planètes alors, on en parle ?”,
et je vous dirai : mais oui, elles le méritent aussi.
Les planètes, en effet, diffèrent en ceci qu'elles ont des positions variables dans le ciel par rapport aux astres fixes ;
c’est même ça que ça veut dire, à l’origine : planêtês en grec signifie errant ou vagabond.
Les planètes ce sont les astres qui errent, qui se déplacent indépendamment des autres astres.
Mais bref ! Les planètes, la Lune et le Soleil, tout ça ne va pas m'intéresser ici.
Ce qui est important avant tout c'est cette sphère des fixes.
Les astronomes ont rapidement compris que les astres fixes sont plus éloignés que la Lune, le Soleil et ces quelques autres astres vagabonds.
La sphère des fixes constituent en quelque sorte le fond, l’arrière-plan de l’univers.
Et donc être “au centre de l’univers”, ce serait précisément être au centre de cette sphère ultime,
le point autour duquel tourne toute la voûte étoilée.
Mais donc pourquoi avait-on de bonnes raisons de penser ça ?
Eh bien, précisément, parce que les astres fixes apparaissent fixes.
Ça ne vous convainc pas ? Alors prenons un exemple pour l’illustrer.
Vous allez voir, c’est super simple.
On va prendre trois boules qui vont faire trois axes fixes.
Tiens, mets-toi là, reste-là, très bien.
Viens un peu plus près, tu seras mieux là. Très bien, ne bouge pas.
Ça c’est le soleil, ça c’est la Terre.
De ce point de vue là, quand on regarde ces trois astres,
on voit que l’astre vert est exactement au milieu des deux astres rouges.
Mais si c’est la Terre qui tourne autour du soleil, ça veut dire que six mois plus tard, la Terre se retrouve de l’autre côté du soleil.
À peu près ici, à un cochonnet près.
Et ce qu’on voit, c’est que l’astre vert est maintenant plus proche de l’astre rouge de gauche
que celui de droite.
Non mais le but, c’est de les lancer les boules. C’est pas d’expliquer des trucs avec comme ça là.
Eh, pète un coup, on était en train de gagner de toutes façons là.
Cette modification de la position d’un astre en fonction de la position de l’observateur,
c’est ce qu’on appelle la parallaxe.
Pour le dire le plus simplement possible, quand on bouge, les positions relatives des choses qu’on observe bougent aussi,
quand bien même celle-ci ne bougent pas.
Donc si l’héliocentrisme est correct
(l’héliocentrisme, par opposition au géocentrisme, c’est l’idée que c’est le Soleil qui est au centre et que la Terre et les autres planètes lui tournent autour),
ça impliquerait que la Terre, à six mois d’intervalle, passe d’un côté à l’autre du soleil,
ce qui fait un sacré bout de chemin, et on s’attendrait dès lors à observer un léger va-et-vient
dans la position des astres fixes, ce qu’on appelle une parallaxe annuelle.
Or, c’est un point sur lequel s’accordent toutes les observations de tous les astronomes,
Galilée compris, dont les observations étaient bien plus précises grâce à l’invention de sa lunette,
on n’observe aucune parallaxe annuelle dans les astres fixes.
Coup dur pour l’héliocentrisme.
L’argument de l’absence de parallaxe, on le trouve déjà chez Aristote.
Et 2000 ans plus tard, lors du procès de Galilée, le cardinal Bellarmin emploiera ce même argument de la parallaxe
pour justifier que Galilée n’avait pas de raisons suffisantes de tenir l’héliocentrisme pour réel.
Et ça a beau être Aristote et un cardinal qui le disent contre Galilée, ça n’en fait pas un mauvais argument.
C’est un très bon argument.
On a tendance à penser rétrospectivement que la science était tout entière du côté des héliocentristes Copernic et Galilée,
mais à vrai dire, les données de l’époque ne permettaient pas de trancher si clairement.
L’héliocentrisme de Copernic avait certes l’avantage de simplifier beaucoup la description du mouvement des planètes,
qui, dans les systèmes géocentristes, devait être décrit par un jeu complexe d’épicycles,
c’est-à-dire des cercles tournant autour de cercle, etc., bref, ça sentait le bricolage.
Mais l’héliocentrisme avait aussi ce gros désavantage d’être bien difficile à réconcilier avec l’absence de parallaxe annuelle
dans les astres fixes.
C’était un sacré problème et vous allez voir que de sa solution découlaient deux conceptions radicalement opposées de l’univers.
La première solution était de n’accepter l’héliocentrisme que pour déterminer le mouvement des planètes,
tout en maintenant l’idée que la sphère des fixes tourne autour de la Terre.
Cela donne le modèle de Tycho Brahé où la Terre est fixe au centre de l’univers,
la Lune et le Soleil tournent autour de la Terre,
et les planètes tournent autour du Soleil (et non de la Terre),
et la sphère des fixes tourne autour de la Terre.
Vous suivez ?
On appelle ça un modèle géo-héliocentriste et tout le monde est content.
En somme, on garde les simplifications de calcul que permet le système héliocentriste pour le mouvement des planètes,
tout en laissant la Terre au centre pour ne pas bousculer au-delà de ça l’ordre du monde, parce que hein, faut pas pousser.
Vous n’en avez peut-être jamais entendu parler, mais Tycho Brahé, grand défenseur de ce modèle, c’est pas le premier crétin venu.
C’est probablement l’astronome le plus important de son temps avec Copernic.
Son modèle géo-héliocentriste a le mérite d’être simple (en tout cas plus simple que le modèle de Ptolémée) et de coller très très bien au mouvement apparent des astres.
Tycho Brahé est un observateur excellent et il est tout à fait prêt à admettre des innovations théoriques quand c’est nécessaire.
Par exemple quand il observe l’apparition d’une nouvelle étoile en 1572, ce qu’on appellera plus tard une supernova,
ça va l’amener à rejeter de vénérables idées aristotéliciennes sur la nature immuables des cieux.
Et Tycho Brahé connaît très bien le travail de Copernic, qu’il admire.
Mais il rejette son héliocentrisme.
Et l’une des principales raisons pour cela, en tout cas celle qu’il met le plus en avant dans ses écrits scientifiques,
c’est qu’il n’observe pas de parallaxe dans la sphère des fixes.
C’est peut-être un détail pour vous, mais pour un astronome du seizième siècle ça veut dire beaucoup.
Ah oui. Épisode 5. Collab Valentine.
Tu sais qu’il y a plein de légendes autour de la mort de Tycho Brahé ?
Ah bah non, je ne savais pas.
Bah voilà. Maintenant, tu sais.
En fait, on sait qu’il est mort en 1601,
à l’âge de 54 ans, à Prague.
Par contre, on ne sait pas de quoi il est mort. Alors, il y a plein de théories un peu obscures, des trucs limite complotistes sur les bords.
Pendant longtemps, la thèse qui a été privilégiée, c’est celle de l’empoisonnement au mercure,
parce que son assistant Kepler aurait voulu profiter du laboratoire en entier, donc il aurait voulu le liquider.
Il y a une autre théorie que je trouve particulièrement croustillante qui dit qu’en fait
ça aurait été le cousin de Tycho Brahé qui aurait voulu le tuer
sur ordre du roi de l’époque, le roi de Danemark,
parce qu’en fait Tycho Brahé aurait fait des choses pas très catholique avec le père et ou la mère du roi.
Et du coup, il a été exhumé deux fois Tycho.
C’est plus que beaucoup de gens.
Il y a des chercheurs qui ont été analysés plein de choses, ses vêtements, ses cheveux, ses machins,…
Et ils ont trouvé des taux de mercure passablement… voilà…
mais pas non plus mortel.
Donc à priori, cette thèse est écartée.
Là, la thèse privilégiée par les enquêteurs, c’est au contraire,
l’insuffisance rénale.
Son assistant Kepler raconte, une source de première main,
que Tycho se serait retenu de faire pipi
lors d’un banquet où il était invité parce qu’il ne voulait pas enfreindre l’étiquette en se levant de table en plein milieu des agapes.
Et du coup, une fois rentré chez lui, il n’arrivait plus à faire pipi,
et il y a une longue agonie comme ça de onze jours, et il est mort après ça.
De s’être retenu de faire pipi. Peut-être.
C’est tragique. C’est absolument tragique.
Et du coup, la légende raconte que, encore une,
pendant ces onzes jours-là, il aurait écrit sa propre épitaphe qui est :
“il a vécu comme un sage, et il est mort comme un con.”
Bon on joue maintenant !
Les héliocentristes ne se laissaient pas démonter et ils pouvaient répondre à l’argument de la parallaxe, bien sûr.
Le problème, c’est que la seule réponse possible était assez... coûteuse disons.
L'héliocentrisme implique qu’il doit y avoir une parallaxe annuelle des astres fixes,
ils ne le contestent pas ; or on n’observe pas de parallaxe,
ça non plus ils ne le contestent pas.
Et donc cette absence d’observation ne peut que s’expliquer que si cette parallaxe
est trop petite pour être observable,
aussi bien à l’oeil nu qu’au moyen de la lunette de Galilée, ou plus tard des premiers télescopes.
Or, qu’est-ce qui fait que la parallaxe est plus ou moins grande, et donc plus ou moins détectable ?
C’est d’une part la distance qui sépare les deux points entre lesquels l’observateur se déplace,
mais aussi la distance entre les astres observés et les points d’observation.
Bon, cette fois-ci, Thibaut, tu gères hein ?
Allez vas-y…
J'ai une idée.
Oh non.
Tenez vos boules.
Regardez, là, du point de vue de la Terre, on a un alignement d’astre
qui est similaire à celui de tout à l’heure, sauf que vous êtes quelques mètres plus loin.
Et donc, quand au bout de six mois, la Terre se retrouve de l’autre côté du soleil,
à nouveau, vous voyez que l’astre vert s’est décalé vers l’astre rouge de gauche,
mais beaucoup moins.
Ah non mais, ils me saoulent avec ses planètes-là, viens Valentine, on se casse.
Si vous vous éloignez suffisamment, ça deviendra quasi imperceptible, même avec des instruments très sensibles.
La réponse des héliocentristes sera donc toujours la même :
si la parallaxe est indétectable, c’est parce que les astres fixes
sont très très très très très très éloignés.
Mais la distance minimale nécessaire semblait vraiment énorme.
Cela impliquait en gros que la distance entre la Terre et le Soleil devait être dérisoire par rapport à la distance
entre la Terre et les plus proches des astres fixes.
Moyennant cette supposition selon laquelle les astres fixes sont extraordinairement éloignés
le système de Copernic et le système de Tycho Brahé font exactement les même prédictions astronomiques
et ne peuvent pas être distingués par là.
Mais cette supposition d’une sphère des fixes extraordinairement éloignée n’est pas anodine !
L’héliocentrisme n’implique pas seulement que la Terre n’est pas au centre de l‘univers,
cela implique aussi que les dimensions de l’univers sont beaucoup, beaucoup, beaucoup plus grandes
que celle du système solaire avec la Terre et les planètes, et qu’entre celui-ci et les restes des étoiles
s’étend un espace vide démesuré !
Alors bien sûr, cette idée d’une distance énorme entre le système solaire et les étoiles nous est familière aujourd’hui
même s’il est difficile de prendre vraiment la mesure de ce que ça signifie.
Mais une telle conception était beaucoup plus difficile à admettre pour un esprit du XVIIe siècle ou avant cela.
Jusque là, l’univers ne paraissaient pas devoir être inconcevablement immense et principalement vide.
Dans le système de Ptolémée, on évaluait la distance Terre-Soleil à 1210 fois le rayon de la Terre,
(ce qui est déjà assez en dessous de la réalité, vu que c’est plutôt 23 000 fois),
et la distance de la Terre à la sphère des fixes restait dans un ordre de grandeur similaire.
Le fait même d’en parler comme d’une sphère, comme d’une “voûte étoilée”,
c’est caractéristique d’une conception d’un monde clos, renfermé au sein de cette voûte.
Ce petit problème de parallaxe avait donc des conséquences assez vertigineuses sur la conception qu’on se fait de l’univers.
Ou bien c’est un monde clos dont les dimensions restent raisonnables, de l’ordre de quelques dizaines de milliers de fois le rayon de la Terre,
et la Terre en occupe le centre ;
ou bien la Terre n’est pas au centre, elle tourne autour du Soleil, et cela implique que l’univers est beaucoup,
beaucoup, beaucoup, beaucoup plus vaste, peut-être infini, qu’un espace vide
absurdement gigantesque nous sépare des plus proches étoiles, et que celle-ci, pour rester visibles de si loin,
doivent être des corps énormes, de la dimension de notre soleil au moins, autrement dit que ce sont d’autres soleils très éloignés.
Et ce point d’ailleurs tend à réfuter l’héliocentrisme compris comme la thèse selon laquelle notre soleil serait au centre de l’univers.
Si l’héliocentrisme a pour conséquence qu’il doit y avoir d’autres soleils très éloignés, pourquoi accorder au nôtre un statut spécial ?
Tout cela semble finalement plutôt pencher en faveur de l’idée qu’il n’y pas du tout de centre de l’univers.
En regardant le ciel, nous ne nous sentirions plus sous une voûte
mais, comme le disait admirablement Pascal,
dans “une sphère infinie dont le centre est partout et la circonférence nulle part”.
Tout ça à cause d’une foutue parallaxe qu’on ne peut pas observer.
Finalement, les preuves se sont accumulées en faveur du mouvement de la Terre,
en particulier à partir du moment où la théorie de la gravitation de Newton a permis de donner une justification physique à ce mouvement.
La Terre tombe sur le soleil comme la flèche tombe sur la Terre,
la mécanique terrestre obéit à la même loi universelle de gravitation que la mécanique céleste.
Il faut bien l’admettre, elle tourne.
Et nous sommes ainsi passés du monde clos des Anciens à l’univers infini des Modernes.
La première estimation précise de la distance d’une étoile, on la doit à l’astronome allemand
Friedrich Wilhelm Bessel, en 1838,
grâce à la méthode de la parallaxe justement,
la précision des télescopes s’étant suffisamment amélioré pour permettre de détecter la parallaxe annuelle des étoiles les plus proches.
Ainsi Bessel estime la distance de l’étoile Cygni 61 à environ 10,5 années-lumière.
Ce qui était assez correcte, la véritable valeur étant un peu supérieure à 11.
Nos plus proches voisines parmi les étoiles sont à une distance de cet ordre de grandeur.
Quelques années-lumières.
Et on pourrait déjà se poser la question :
à quel point c’est au-delà de l’idée qu’on se faisait de la sphère des fixes dans l’Antiquité ?
Difficile d’avoir des distances précises, mais sachant que chez Ptolémée la distance Terre-Soleil est de 1210 fois le rayon de la Terre
et en admettant que la distance à la sphère des fixes n’est pas cent fois supérieur à cela,
l’ordre de grandeur de la sphère des fixes ne dépasserait pas
100 ou 200 000 fois le rayon de la Terre.
Traduit en km, ça donne quelque chose de l’ordre du milliard de km.
Les étoiles les plus proches sont à plusieurs années lumière, et une année-lumière c’est presque 10 000 milliards de km.
Ainsi, nos plus proches voisines dans l’univers sont déjà éloignées de nous d’une distance qui est supérieure d’un facteur 10 000 ou 100 000
à l’idée que l’on se faisait, dans l’Antiquité de la distance des astres les plus éloignés.
Ouais, il a bien grossi, l’univers.
Et ce n’est qu’un début.
Dans les années 1920, les astronomes commencent à comprendre que la nébuleuse d’Andromède est en fait une autre galaxie
constituée de centaines de milliards d’étoiles,
et on parvient à estimer son éloignement au moyen de différentes méthodes qui s’accordent sur une valeur proprement vertigineuse.
Environ 2,5 millions d’années-lumières.
C’est difficile de prendre la mesure de ce qu’un tel éloignement veut dire.
Une année-lumière, presque 10 000 milliards de kilomètres, c’est déjà incroyablement démesuré pour nous.
Que veut dire cette distance multipliée 2,5 millions de fois entre nous et la galaxie d'Andromède ?
Et ce n’est que notre plus proche voisine !
On observera plus tard encore des galaxies éloignées de milliards d’années-lumières.
À nouveau, c’est un saut d’ordre de grandeur.
Et ce saut des étoiles aux galaxies est même beaucoup plus important que le précédent.
L'idée que l'on se faisait de la taille de l'univers avait été multiplié par 10 000 ou 100 000 environ
n passant de la sphères des fixes des Anciens aux étoiles éloignées des Modernes,
mais en passant ensuite des étoiles aux galaxies,
un astronome du début du vingtième siècle aura vu dans sa carrière
la taille de l’univers,
ou plus exactement l’éloignement des objets les plus lointains qu’il peut observer,
multipliée par un facteur de l’ordre du milliard !
Tout ça au cours de juste quelques décennies de recherches.
C’est un vertige tellement inconcevable qu’il semble avoir passé presque inaperçu.
Je remplace Arnaud.
Et pour ton histoire d’univers, on est quand même au centre de l’univers observable.
Oui, on peut dire ça. Mais bon, l’univers observable, c’est pas l’univers tout court.
C’est quoi l’univers observable ?
Bah, la vitesse de la lumière, elle est finie,
donc plus tu vas regarder quelque chose de loin,
plus tu vas regarder quelque chose qui est loin dans le temps.
Tu vas remonter le temps.
Et comme, tu sais, que l’univers est en expansion,
quand tu remontes dans le passé de l’univers,
t’arrive à un point où il est très concentré, il y a à peu près 13,8 milliards d’années,
il est ultra dense, tu as ce qu’on appelle le Big Bang,
première lumière de l’univers.
Et au-delà, tu ne peux pas l’observer finalement.
Et donc, l’ensemble de notre univers observable,
ça représente une bulle de 13,8 milliards d’années, et nous, on est pile poil au centre.
Oui mais bon, au-delà de ça, on a aucune raison de penser que l’univers ne continue pas de de s’étendre
et même ma question de savoir si l’univers est infini ou fini en physique aujourd’hui, ce n’est pas tranché.
Et du coup là, je me sens tout effrayé par le silence éternel de ces espaces infinis. Et je ne vois vraiment pas comment je pourrais continuer à jouer à la pétanque.
Non, c’est au-dessus de mes forces.
Merci d’avoir regardé cette vidéo, n’hésitez pas à vous abonner, à discuter en commentaire ou sur le discord du Vortex.
Est-ce que vous trouvez que l’univers est beaucoup trop grand ?
Vous avez quatre heures.
Ciao !